i gave you my body and soul now that the
outlander cast and crew are
finally back filming season six we won't
have to wait much longer for new
episodes
in the meantime we wanted to take a look
at some of the best scenes that never
made it into the episodes from season
one
through five but if they had they might
just have changed
everything nice contradiction nerd
just a quick note if you haven't had
time to catch up on all five seasons of
outlander
there are going to be some serious
spoilers ahead that doesn't sound so bad
season five of outlander brought about a
ton of changes for the fraser clan
but one of the most exciting and
surprising developments was the return
of young ian or not so young ian
as claire points out in this deleted
scene i'm not sure we can call him young
ian anymore
clearly claire and jamie are thrilled
about his return
so much so that jamie calls it a miracle
but like everything in outlander
nothing is quite as simple as it seems
and claire is left wondering just
what secrets young ian might be hiding i
wonder why now
jamie and roger have never had an easy
relationship with that whole mistaken
identity leading to roger being sold
into slavery thing from season four
but finally in season five we see them
bonding a little more
and this fun deleted scene would have
shown just how much their relationship
has changed it's an elegant blade
maybe a sword fight isn't the usual
display of family bonding but
in the world of outlander it makes
perfect sense
in season 5 roger goes through some
serious trauma and loses his ability to
speak
in this deleted scene brianna asks jaime
for some advice on how to get him back
to his old
self he can't talk he's just choosing
not to
we all remember how claire and jamie
struggled to reconnect after jaime's
horrible experience with jack randall
so he knows exactly what she's going
through and
that there's a way out it's easier to
say losing murta was one of the most
tragic moments from the fifth season and
we're still
not sure we're quite over it that's why
we're a little sad that this scene was
cut between jaime and lord john at
marta's grave
first of all because we just can't get
enough of their friendship
and seriously because it shows how far
they've come since lord john was
stationed at the prison where jaime and
murtagh were trapped for so long
you think of something only claire and
jamie could make a conversation about
mold as romantic as any marriage
proposal
and that's exactly what they do in this
sadly deleted scene
even though we know that claire has
started trying to develop penicillin
penicillium mold should look a bit like
a paintbrush
jamie wasn't aware of what she was up to
and this would have given her the chance
to share it with him
one of the big plot lines in season four
was murtaz fight against the cruel
landlords and debt collectors
enforcing impossibly high taxes on the
tenants in this hilariously amazing
deleted scene
we see murtaugh defending marsai against
two of these very debt collectors
it's so heartwarming because even though
they aren't related by blood
murta is marsai's grandfather by
choice we are in agreement we
love young ian and his half-wolf best
friend rolo
so we were excited to see this deleted
scene which shows
just how the two first met even though
he means well
young ian does have a habit of getting
in a little over his head
but when he sees the adorable and
mistreated rolo
he knows he has to try and take him home
it may be the cutest thing to have ever
happened on outlander
what do you think of that but a name
when jamie had to give up his son
william
it was one of the most heartbreaking
decisions he has ever had to make
but something that made it a little
better was knowing that the boy would be
taken in by lord john and give him a
good life
in this deleted scene we get to see what
a good father lord john is
yes and how his love for william goes
beyond simply
doing a favor for jaime
john gray became one of jaime's best
friends he was simply a sympathetic
prison guard responsible for keeping
jaime and martha in jail
this powerful deleted scene shows a side
of lord john that we rarely get to see
tell me why you escaped furious hurt and
betrayed by jaime's attempt to escape
and ready to punish murtaugh for it
luckily his true nature is kind and
non-violent and that's what wins out in
the end
return the prisoner to his cell clare
has spent a lot of time patiently
explaining things about the future to
jaime and in this
cutscene from their long-awaited season
3 reunion
is one of the best nice contradiction
nerd
their relationship has never been like
anyone else's
and for most people pillow talk doesn't
usually involve knives and surgery
but somehow once again claire and jamie
make even the most unromantic topics
seem
like love poems they try to affect
healing
by means of a knife jamie is without a
doubt
a protector he has sworn oaths to
protect those around him
and does such a good job of taking care
of everyone that we sometimes forget
that he can
feel just as vulnerable and afraid as
anyone else
this cut scene shows that perfectly and
is a different side of jaime
while we have always known that he has
religious beliefs
seeing him pray for the safety of those
he loves gives us a glimpse into his
worries and fears
the beginning of season two was rough
jamie had just come out of his horrific
experience with jack randall
and was definitely not over the trauma
of it all claire
ultimately helped him find his way back
but the road was
not an easy one as this deleted scene
shows perfectly
give me your hand even though he wanted
to move past it
this clip would have shown just how hard
that can actually be
that's nice isn't it master raymond was
one of the only
real friends that claire made in france
and this deleted scene shows just how
much he cared for her
thank you i could use a friend he
clearly thinks
very highly of claire and goes out of
his way to warn her about just how
dangerous saint germain
actually is saint germain is not an
adversary to be taken lightly
claire's alter ego ladam blanche has
helped her strike fear into the hearts
of more than one superstitious man
as the seasons have gone on but this
deleted scene would have provided so
much more insight into
why the name scares so many people when
fergus tells her that people believe
la don blanche was actually a sorceress
let them blossom
we have to wonder who else might have
thought the same thing a sorceress
we all know that jamie and claire would
have been amazing parents to their first
child
and that jamie has always deserved the
chance to actually raise one of his
babies
this cut scene that takes place before
claire loses the child
shows just how tender the two are with
one another i love you too
and what a loving family they would have
created together if they had been given
the chance
it also adds a sad piece of
foreshadowing when jamie says that he
wants 12 children
as we now know that he will never get
that chance
you want 12 children why not
the end of season 2 was a hard one for
claire and jamie
but this cut scene would have made them
and us
feel a little better even though they
have been through so much tragedy seeing
them come back together and start to
heal as a team
is exactly the kind of band-aid we
needed after
such a hard season i gave you my body
and soul
all the way back in season one the
marriage of claire and jamie came about
pretty abruptly
and left us with a few questions and we
weren't the only ones
this deleted scene might have cleared a
few things up like why exactly it was
jamie who had to marry claire
if you marry an english woman you can
never be chief of clan mackenzie
and it turns out that dougal had a few
ulterior motives about the whole thing
from the start
i thought that by marrying her to the
lad it would be a fine way of showing my
appreciation
after jamie made the mistake of
punishing claire she understandably
banned him from her bedroom while
waiting to be let back in
jaime encounters gayless in this deleted
scene while we all know how things
turned out with galas in the end it is
interesting to see her stick up for
claire
don't worry jamie and also reveal that
her potions can do a lot of harm if she
wishes them to
he doesn't do much laboring in any
position
if we had it our way they wouldn't cut a
single moment from outlander what about
you
let us know how you feel about these
amazing deleted scenes in the comments
and don't forget to hit subscribe to
keep up with the latest from the things
you